so we all know the term metrosexuals
that straight guys that dress sort of
like gay guys then we did a story about
two months ago on Spore no sexuals these
are also straight guys we are now taking
this to the next level with all the
shirtless selfies and show it off
muscles and tattoos blah blah blah now
there's been an interesting discussion
going on on reddit about high sexuals
and these are straight guys supposedly
straight guys who when they smoke weed
they become temporarily gay yeah that's
right and we've got a quote from reddit
this is from one of the high sectionals
he says I feel very attracted to girls
and not at all to men when sober and
when I get high I just want a big [ __ ]
to suck and a man who [ __ ] the [ __ ] out
of me doesn't not that it really bothers
me since I'm still attracted to girls
while high but sometimes I feel weirded
by male friends with whom I don't
usually feel attracted to so I thought
this was kinda interesting cuz I've
never heard of this before you know
people get drunk like I guess pardon
this couple things going on here so
first of it experimentation is more
accepted for girls right - dude version
of a girl being like while I was in
college and we drink tequila let me made
out and I don't know I don't really like
girls but women are kind of pretty when
I'm drunk so like that's this is the
dude reddit version of that so raffiq
dude yeah don't get that graphic with it
yeah is that partly here is this just
that guys are far more repressed
especially straight guys are far more
repressed about their sexuality so in a
weird way these guys get high and it's
like it's just giving them like 5% well
that guys seem to be wondering more than
5% but finds that it's it's not just
high it's you know if you get drunk if
you're on LSD if you're on ecstasy
whatever like yeah the more you
experiment presumably if your sexuality
is already something you're struggling
with or not but it's repressed yeah
that's gonna allow it to come out or
manifest itself in some way yeah I think
people just need a label for everything
yeah thanks to that so I think that in
sexuality which most people know is a
gray area just from our fantasies
whether they lean towards heterosexual
or homosexual all of our or everything
in between fantasies are still
inherently gray and we keep them to
ourselves but once you can label them
like oh I'm into bond
oh that's very Fifty Shades of Grey once
we give it this sort of label like high
sexual now you finally can understand
why you're having these thoughts so
you're a dude with something and
identify with someone else who
experienced exactly so if your dude and
you even having some thoughts towards
other men that are a little bit sexual
and they happen to get a little bit
stronger when you're loosened up and a
little bit high well now you have a
label for it it's high sexual so now
it's more acceptable because you found
another group of people or other people
that can identify with you and it's
really just human nature
sex is do you guys think that the next
sort of evolution of our sexuality now
that the gay thing I think is pretty
much behind us no pun intended like I
think basically that's pretty much out
of the way and the Supreme Court is
probably going to finish it off in June
that the point is that that do you guys
think that straight guy's sexuality is
the next thing that's going to evolve a
little bit like a couple friends the
other day about why a threesome with two
guys and a girl is called a devil's
threesome like why I ever heard that I
had neither and apparently it's a thing
and I was like well you clearly a guy
came up with that term three of us have
ever heard of the devil's threesome
that's clearly another label to make it
okay to do it because I feel like all
three of us are liberal enough and you
know sexually educated enough we're good
I mean we probably know about stuff like
the donkey punch and the dirty sanchez
and we talked about the devil devil's
threesome so that's clearly another
label to justify yeah yeah you realize
that 90% of our viewers just pause this
to go Google dump don't do you think
when you combine gay and weed that this
is like the right-wingers nightmare like
because this is what they fear they fear
partly that that straight pee or that
gays are turning yeah and then that we
now you throw a weed into it too and
you've got this a lot they feel a lot of
meat for them right lose their own
control I feel like if you're so worried
about marijuana turning you gay then
that means that you are afraid that
there's some part of you that would
really like to be gay once you've become
high on the
crazy devil's threesome drug oh yeah of
course this is there anybody who's
conservatives nightmare because
conservatives and the lot is about
control and does a lot about denying
these urges because you've chosen to
take the higher path and Road so to them
this is you know the worst-case scenario
is you're gonna hand that we'd Nebraska
Delia this is complete hedonism
unfettered and yeah yeah so final
thought on this if they could prove
actually that weed makes you a little
gay does that help or hurt the gays do
you think if they found out they if you
smoke weed you can get temporarily gay
you have a gay old time with your
friends I think that it would hurt it it
would hurt it because here's the thing
is the strength of the argument for gay
rights is that it's this inherent thing
that you have no control over and no say
over cuz why on earth would anyone
choose to be gay if they could be
straight which that argument just for
the record real quick like that argument
or even like that cuz I don't think
anything's wrong with it so it may be
right that convenience it's not as
convenient as being straight yeah you
know presumably not yes but I think that
if if there if there's ever a choice
element then that makes the plight much
harder because it'll just be assumed
that if you can switch back to being
straight you will at some point and that
the legislation doesn't exist for
someone who chooses to dye their hair
blonde and it doesn't doesn't choose to
you know exercise or whatever that might
be but if there's some inherent trait
that's making you a certain way you
should be afforded the same sort of
rights as everyone else so I guess final
thought would be if we had the
old-fashioned threesome the two girl one
guy three what would that be called
fun that's just a good old time like
everyone should try
[Music]